what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and yesterday we got the
first official teaser trailer for thor
love and thunder and it did not
disappoint it was worth the wait in the
trailer we saw the new thor we saw him
getting in shape after he was broke or
an avengers in-game we saw the guardians
of the galaxy we saw zeus and olympus
and we got our first look at jane
foster's the mighty thor however one
person that we did not get a first look
at is gore the godbutcher the villain of
this film who is going to be played by
christian bale now there are many
theories going around right now about
why we didn't get our first look at gore
the god butcher we know that there were
reshoots going on very recently for thor
love and thunder so maybe those reshoots
had to do with christian bale's
character gore and maybe his character
wasn't ready to be shown yet or maybe
they're saving this first look for a
possible cameo in moon knight after all
gore is the god butcher and gods play a
very prominent role in the moon knight
series so who knows but yesterday marvel
studios did roll out a new synopsis for
the film that does mention gore the god
butcher even though we don't see him in
the trailer so let's break down what it
says and compare it to what we see in
the trailer we also do have a cool
spider-man easter egg to talk about
today as well one relating to thor love
and thunder and one relating to doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
that gives us signs that perhaps toby
maguire spider-man is going to be in the
film so let's get started and of course
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so this official plot synopsis
was released yesterday from marvel
studios to the press when the trailer
and the new poster came out for thor
love and thunder and here's what it
reads a new trailer and poster are now
available for marvel studios as thor
love and thunder offering long awaited
clues to what's in store for the god of
thunder the film finds thor chris
hemsworth on a journey unlike anything
he's ever faced a quest for inner peace
but his retirement is interrupted by a
galactic killer known as gore the
godbutcher christian bale who seeks the
extinction of the gods to combat the
threat thor enlists the help of king
valkyrie tessa thompson korg taikawatiti
and ex-girlfriend jane foster who of
course is natalie portman who to thor's
surprise inexplicably wields his magical
hammer mjolnir as the mighty thor
together they embark on a harrowing
cosmic adventure to uncover the mystery
of the god butcher's vengeance and stop
him before it's too late directed by
taiko atiti of course and produced by
kevin feige and brad winterbomb now
what's interesting about this is that
they don't really mention the guardians
of the galaxy in this plot synopsis even
though they were basically almost in the
full trailer for thor love and thunder
yesterday however it was a teaser
trailer and it looks like they're very
much not trying to show us a lot about
the movie they did tease some things
which we'll talk about but for those who
aren't like us who follow all of this
stuff every day you probably don't know
that christian bale is going to be
playing the villain and that it scored
the god butcher in fact there is
actually no mention of a villain in the
entire trailer there's only one
particular scene that shows us that
somebody is out there killing things but
again it's interesting that they don't
mention the guardians that makes me
believe that everything that we saw in
the thor love and thunder teaser for the
most part all the parts with the
guardians of the galaxy is probably in
the first beginning part of the movie
whether that's a quarter of it or not
even a quarter of it it leads me to
believe that they're only in it in the
beginning thor kind of tries to find
himself he goes along with the guardians
of the galaxy across the galaxy but then
they take off and they leave thor and
korg which we saw in the trailer and
they're probably not in the movie
anymore they're off to find gamora and
meet adam warlock and do a bunch of
stuff that we'll see in guardians 3. but
thanks to the synopsis we know kind of
what happens here the synopsis says thor
is on a quest for inner peace and this
is most likely the time where he's with
the guardians and it says but his
retirement is interrupted by a galactic
killer known as gore the godbutcher who
seeks the extinction of the gods and
thanks to this plot synopsis i think we
actually know what a few scenes in the
trailer are now now one is a scene that
is taken straight from the comics which
i love it's a thor and korg staring at a
massive beast who is apparently dead now
this actually comes from thor god of
thunder number three in the comics and
it's actually gore the god butcher's
debut comic now this beast is actually
falagar the behemoth the patron god of
the galactic frontier so this isn't
actually a bad bean this isn't a bad
beast here in the trailer thor didn't
just come across this beast and fight
him and kill him this was actually an
old friend of his in the comics him and
falagar would come across each other
while they were traveling the galaxy
they would cross paths and they were
buddies unfortunately falagar ends up
going missing and in the comics and it
looks like in the movie as well thor is
actually the person who comes across him
and finds him dead now he actually died
on his home planet and he's surrounded
by the people of the planet who pray by
his side every day for his resurrection
but in the comics and again it looks
like in the movie too this is how
everybody finds out that gore the god
butcher is going around killing gods and
it's most likely this scene right here
that cuts thor's journey of peace and
discovery short thor realizes that
something is going around killing gods
and not only has this person killed a
god but also his friend and thor is a
god himself so this is probably quite
concerning but i'm guessing that this is
actually what takes thor to olympus
there's a part in the synopsis that says
to combat the threat thor enlists the
help of king valkyrie korg and
ex-girlfriend jane foster who is now the
mighty thor and in the teaser trailer if
you look at one particular scene of
olympus you can look at the bottom and
you can see this whole crew walking into
olympus and if you notice there are two
red capes there so one is thor and one
is jane foster as the mighty thor now
why are thor and the group going to
olympus well falagar was actually an
extremely powerful god he was the
champion of the tournament of the
immortals for five centuries straight
and they say that falagar wrestled black
holes just for fun so the fact that this
god is dead is a very very big deal
because it takes something extremely
powerful to kill him now we don't really
know much about the tournament of the
immortals but perhaps that's where
olympus gets connected here thor finds
falugar dead so he goes to olympus to
find out more and he goes to talk to
zeus who was teased in this trailer and
we know is going to be played by russell
crowe and as we can imagine from here
thor is going to bring this to the
attention of zeus who in his realm is
the god of the gods and we assume that
he's going to warn him and seek out
information as well and who knows maybe
he'll join the fight because like the
synopsis says gore the god butcher is
out to make all of the gods extinct so
that's a problem for zeus as well so be
sure to let me know what you think about
all of this and like i said we do have
some quick little spider-man easter eggs
one of which was spotted in the thor
love and thunder trailer and in
spider-man no way home in spider-man no
way home's first scenes that look back
at mysterio's death you can see at the
bottom of the screen a message saying
political turmoil continues in new
asgard and this directly connects with a
scene that we saw of valkyrie in the
thor love and thunder teaser now in this
scene there's a sign to the right that
talks about an energy crisis but it
looks like tessa thompson's valkyrie
wants nothing to do with this meeting
it's a very worldly meeting and she's an
asgardian now the king of asgard so the
political turmoil is most likely
referring to the fact that the world
probably wants some sort of a political
connection to asgard and valkyrie wants
nothing to do with it after all you have
to imagine how the people of earth view
the asgardians they view them as gods so
it would make sense that these big
countries would want asgard on their
side as allies but again valkyrie
probably wants nothing to do with it and
we have one more big easter egg that
comes in the form of a tied ad combined
with a multiverse of madness promo in
this ad huang accidentally spills
something on doctor strange's cloak of
levitation he says that he has to wash
the cloak but the cloak runs away and as
he's chasing the cloak we see a truck in
one of the scenes that says joe's pizza
parlor serving new york oven fried pizza
since 1932. now joe's pizza is actually
seen in the opening scenes of spider-man
2 it's who peter parker works for we
even see it on his bike helmet it says
joe's pizza and if you notice the
address it actually says bleecker street
and if you recall dr strange's sanctum
in new york is on bleecker street so
could this be a sign that toby maguire
is going to appear in multiverse of
madness rumors have been going around
for a while about this and this is
another hint at it so be sure to let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]
[Music]
you